[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
or as I prefer to think of it dear
Johnny hey it's a comedy podcast about
death where me and my brother John we
answer your question give you devious
advice and bring you all the week's news
from both Mars and AFC Wimbledon hey
John how are you I am okay
Hank I don't know if you're aware of
this but I have just announced that I
have a new book coming out in October oh
yes that's completely new information to
me have no I won't do it would you like
to ask some questions about it because
I'd be happy to answer them I feel like
you're not allowed to answer any of the
questions every time anybody yes I'm
allowed to answer I'm allowed to answer
whether it's available for pre-order now
it is and I'm allowed to answer when it
is going to be published October 10th
John are all copies going to be signed
no not all copies will be signed
however 200,000 or maybe hopefully
slightly more will be signed and there's
a special ISBN for the signed copies but
if you preorder from your local
bookstore you should be able to get a
signed copy no problem I that's not a
promise because a lot of pre-orders
won't be signed it has a large first
print run but that's what I would do I
would through it or from from my local
bookstore if it were me uh-huh III
should go do that right now I'll see you
later this was a good pot John I enjoyed
greatly Hank and you know what if you
want to cancel the pod so that you can
preorder Turtles all the way down my new
book coming out October 10th that is
just fine by me
okay well I'm not actually going to do
that because I feel like I have an
obligation to do something else first
and also my local book store will be
there this afternoon when I go there so
one of the characters in this book Hank
is a is a small-time poet you know like
a 17 year old kid poet not like not like
a grown-up poet so I thought maybe I
would I would read one of his poems for
for the short poem today on the BA
that's special so we're getting a little
sneak preview I don't want to get in
trouble with my publisher who's
constantly screaming at me never to
answer questions about the book or say
anything about it but I am going to read
you this poem that was submitted by an
anonymous user something something
something it's called last Ducks of
autumn it's possible that I've read this
before by the
in an earlier episode of the pod and to
tributed it to an anonymous user then to
if so I apologize the phone's called the
last Ducks of autumn the leaves are gone
you should be too
I'd be going if I were you but then
again Here I am walking alone in the
frigid dawn last Ducks of autumn by
Davis Oh was their slant rhyme in that
it's that 17-year old poet really into
Dickinson yeah I don't feel like I can
talk about that I'm just gonna let's
move on to questions from our listeners
that's all the insight we get John okay
this one is from Danny who asks dear
Hank and John this is obviously for you
I'm moving to a city for nursing school
Portland Oregon that has not just one
but two professional soccer team the
timbers the men's soccer then the wards
yeah women's yeah you knew this I did
I've always wanted to have a local
soccer team to root for and I plan on
attending the games but my question is
how do I attend the game to that looking
/ acting like an obvious newbie is their
behavior I should avoid so I don't act
disrespectfully is there some sort of
abridged version of soccer game play
rule / fouls that I can look into it
understand what the heck is going on
bath bombs and goalies Danny well I mean
the Portland thorns were founded in 2012
so I would argue that all of their fans
are relatively new to the team the
Portland Timbers are not that much older
you know like the great thing about
soccer in America is that everybody's
new joining up right now
it's like Fairweather fans and it's like
well it no it's just this one season
yeah I mean they're they're the of
course there are the occasional like
there are lots of diehards who will be
like oh I've been a timber season ticket
holder since way back in the halcyon
days of 2009 but I actually find one of
the things I really like about soccer
fandom in the u.s. it's is that it's
very welcoming and
open and inclusive there's always an
element of like you know do you even
know the rules or the culture or
whatever but the cool thing about you
know being part of a soccer culture
that's relatively new is that it's still
forming itself it's still deciding what
it means to be a thorns' van or a
Timbers fan and I think that's I think
that's really cool so just learn a
couple songs and you'll be fine in fact
I have attended a Portland Timbers game
and so I know most of their songs there
aren't that many of them Henry still
sings one of them when I read I root for
the Timbers which you know I don't think
it's gonna go down in history as one of
the greatest soccer songs but they're
you one just use that one you'll be fine
Danny I almost am tempted to ask like
what do people do all game during a
soccer game but John I'm not gonna ask
that question because I like hockey and
I go watch hockey and I know exactly
what you do it's a very similar kind of
experience I assume yeah because there's
a lot of like a lot of like back and
forth and not a lot of goalscoring so
they're similar in that way and what you
do is you like get food and you talk
about stuff and you like are watchin the
game but you're also hanging out and
it's not just about the game it's also
about who you go with and and the people
that you meet when you're there so yeah
it's kind of strange to think like okay
I'm gonna I'm gonna become a soccer fan
and I'm just gonna sit here for three
hours right it's nice to go with friends
for sure it's only two hours that's one
of the other benefits of soccer but but
it is nice to go with friends but I also
think it's a it's a good way to it's you
know it can be a good way to meet people
it's not a good way for me to meet
people because I am Way too introverted
to ever strike up a conversation with
someone at a soccer game but it's a good
way for some people to meet people I'm
told anyway Hank I guess the Portland
Timbers are our MLS team now whether we
like it or not that's who we root for
that's yep that's our that's our people
when we really root for the Timbers and
I don't root much and you know what that
that means Hank that we've just made
enemies of the vast majority of American
MLS fans so suck it people of
Kansas City gets a good I don't even
like you
residents of Las Vegas not totally sure
who has the MLS franchises to be
perfectly frank with you yeah I feel
that job I know Orlando has one ah
what's it called I believe it's called
Orlando City FC which is hilarious
because having lived in Orlando for 12
years
Hank and I can both attest to the fact
that not once was it ever referred to by
anyone living there as a city Orlando
City is a weird yeah that's weird yeah
and instead of instead of FC like it is
in the UK it's SC for soccer that's how
they should have called it Orlando
collection of suburbs yeah SC Orlando
loosely knit together community that
exists mostly in the form of roads and
collective imagination this question
comes from a Mason who writes dear Hank
and John how do you get a teenager who
doesn't want to drive to drive thanks I
guess this is my mom's question Mason no
no wait wait whose mom what Mason's mom
is wondering how do you get a teenager
who doesn't want to drive Oh to drive oh
so Mason's mom was like Mason that
podcast you listen to ask them a
question for me about you lazy Mason
doesn't want to do so I don't think it's
that Mason is lazy I'm just purely
theorizing here obviously we don't have
a ton of information in this question I
think Mason is rightly afraid of the
power that comes with driving sure it is
it is a very dangerous thing that we do
probably right up there at the top
actually there was a study that came out
a couple days ago that showed that
preventable deaths in the United States
are rising dramatically not because of
our health care system or anything like
that but entirely because of two causes
one being the opioid crisis and the
other being distracted driving
so people texting while driving it's
possible that Mason just wants to keep
texting and correctly things that you
cannot do that while driving
you cannot I didn't want to emphasize
that statistic though Hank because I
think all of us have moments have
distracted driving where we think like
well this is okay it's not it's one of
these single greatest public health
problems in the world today it is a very
serious problem do not get on your phone
while you're driving yeah yeah yeah I
see it all that I see it so frequently
and it I I just I the other day we were
crossing the street and it's a four-lane
Street and there's and one like one car
and one of the lanes stopped and then
the car in the like Far Lane didn't and
so we like stood there in front of this
car as this other car like this person
was on their phone and I was like this
is me and my my wife and my child and I
was just like you just like it like in
it in a slightly different situation
that could have gone very very bad yeah
and I was really really upset about it
but but to Mason's question I mean what
I mean how long are we gonna have people
driving anymore even like when does it
actually become I mean for many people
in the world it is not necessary to have
a car at all and already we have uber
and it might be cheaper for many people
to just uber around rather than drive
and you have to worry about parking you
have to worry about owning a car which
is an expense and also maleic work you
have to maintain this thing and you have
to buy they have to figure out how like
all that stuff is a cost not just the
cost of the vehicle so and then soon
enough we will have self-driving cars
and then you really won't need one and
and it's sort of like like imagining the
way that stick shifts are today like
some people can drive stick and I can't
I feel like in the future that will he
people who can drive and people who
can't and it would be just as weird to
know how to drive as it is currently to
know how to drive a stick shift I mean I
think your utopian vision of autonomous
cars flooding the market in the next
three years is a little unrealistic I'm
just going to go ahead and say that and
I also don't don't know that the
solution for Mason is necessarily to
you just wait
so mason it depends on why you don't
like driving but if you but for me I
remember being very stressed out about
driving when I was 15 and 16 because I
was like this car weighs a lot and it
seems kind of like a miracle to me every
time a car accident doesn't happen like
every time I am at an intersection I am
astonished by the fact that this has
been successfully navigated by all
parties involved and that is that is a
good not a bad thing to be thinking
about it is not a bad thing to be
remembering in my opinion but I think
like driving gets better like a lot of
things the more you do it the less
stressful it becomes so I would
recommend baby steps baby steps I'm a
big fan of baby steps saying cuz you
know absolutely John this question comes
to us from Sarah who asks dear green
brothers I am currently staring at the
grace pickled walls of an airport and I
was wondering why are there so many
birds in here yeah they get here right
they pre check is this a thing phurba
phurba phurba I don't know what that
means
Sarah I think it means words words words
ah good good good yeah I mean how do you
think birds get places they got to go to
the airport uh that is incorrect
they got it they're going they're going
on vacation or maybe it's a work I don't
know pleasure business whatever all the
same reasons people are at the airport I
mean I'm trying to guess and you but
it's such a stupid joke I don't know
what to do with it okay yes and also
they check their little bird bags ads
fair hold on yeah yeah they check their
little bird bags yes and the birds are
I'm not very good at this game
I was ank good I was a terrible like I
was the worst improviser in all of the
improv classes I ever took people would
be like like what huh and I would just
bend I would I would freeze a lot but
not while playing the The Improv game
freeze just I would just freeze
[Laughter]
yeah yeah I apologize John I shouldn't
have thrown you into that that deep dark
improv water there with with the birds
checking their their little tiny bird if
anything is all the listeners to this
podcast are telling themselves amazing
jokes that I should be telling right now
and I'm a hyper conscious of that I'm
literally the least qualified person
listening to this podcast currently when
it comes to making birds in airport
jokes even though I know a lot about
airports the truth is that airports are
constantly exposed to air weird thing to
me a job yeah it's like aren't airports
like the most secure building we have
except for like jail right yeah like
like it's not easy to get into an area
the door I can't yeah I mean how hard is
it like the doors are always closed the
boarding the moment the boarding door
closes it cannot be reopened but yeah I
have asked too many times the jet way is
like an airlock right it's like on one
end there's a door and on the other end
there's a door and if there's a bird in
there alright the outside door and let
it go that way also is there a is there
a place in contemporary life worse for
birds than an airport you know I don't
know that that's true actually I think
if I were a bird I might really like
living in an airport it depends oh yeah
living in an airport maybe but I'll tell
you what you won't like getting to the
airport because of all the jet engines
there and suck up your body and kill you
once you're in there you're safe but
when you're out on the tarmac that's not
a good spot yeah no that's what I'm
saying getting into the airport is one
of the most dangerous moves a bird can
make now maybe life inside the airport
is awesome although I suspect not I
suspect there's like one bird catcher
employed by every airport he's like out
there trying to get you and it's like a
children's picture book situation you
know yeah the bird just wants to be free
and there's this evil dog catch bird
catcher who's like out trying to get
it's a great premise for a children's
book but it's not an easy way to live
your life yeah I mean that you don't get
rained on that's nice the climate is
controlled and I imagine there's lots of
snacks around people never finish in
their Pringles at the airport but sure
which is which is why I like it when
some times I see
like this is there's a family this isn't
like one bird there's like a generations
of birds happening here oh I think you I
think you've just uncovered what it is
Hank what is it's not that birds are
always coming into the airport it's that
once upon a time there were two birds in
the airport and now years later we're on
like the ninth generation of swallows
like the the swallows that you see
currently in the Detroit Airport III
assume that sara is in the Detroit
Airport I've seen birds in a few
airports but mostly in the Detroit
Airport III think like the birds that
you're seeing in that situation not they
have never known life outside the
airport did their parents nor did their
grandparents those birds got in pre 9/11
when airports were basically just like
open to the world the Swiss cheese
that's right that's what happened we
figured it out we have solved it Sara
that's where the birds came from also
they fly into their vacations and work
trips some of them are in bird
first-class and some fur and bird coach
and it's sort of like a weird societal
division between the birds great call
back to your bad joke this is from TJ
writes Dear John and Hank I've heard
that the largest fear from scientists
about the polar ice caps melting is the
fact that there might be ancient
bacteria that we have never been exposed
to before inside that would be freed
once melted I don't know that that's the
largest fear from scientists but it's
certainly the largest fear from Haifa
can dry achill scientists like myself I
was wondering how true this might be and
how much of a problem it would cause if
we don't know how to combat the diseases
that might be unearthed by the melting
of the polar ice caps especially now
that we've pulled out of the Paris
climate sorry for the new fear of
possible death TJ TJ don't worry you
didn't add any new fears of death to my
life buddy I've been worried about
bacteria that are hiding that will be
revealed by the climate for literally
decades so TJ the situation is depends
on what you mean by ancient because like
if they're like bacteria if like
co-evolved with their hosts
and viruses and and fungi and all these
things so so like if there's something
that's like from pre-human times it's
very unlikely that they'd be able to
infect us just because we have a lot of
systems for dealing with bacteria but
they're there are concerns for example
sometimes you have you have like and
like anthrax will do this where like
like an animal will die infected with
anthrax and then we'll get all up in the
animal and then they'll get buried under
permafrost for a long long time and then
look at unearthed and suddenly that the
anthrax spores are like woohoo and go
off and mostly they kill reindeer but
occasionally it kills people the big one
that like that that scares me is like
smallpox has been a real box there is no
smallpox on earth except in laboratories
but can smallpox survive frozen for a
long time it can and has the last time
this happened was it like the turn of
the last century so like in the night or
early 1900s a body that was infected
with smallpox like that had been buried
in a grave like melted how long for how
long I don't know how long it had been I
can't I I don't have that information in
my head I wish I did but you uh yeah
that person then that there were then
people who got smallpox from that and
that's bummer because because smallpox
is easy to deal with if you know you're
about to get it but hard to deal with
once you get it Hank on this front
though I just want to say something that
I think is generally true which is that
it would obviously be very bad if
smallpox came back to human beings that
would be a huge problem correct um but
we already know for a fact there is no
question that climate change is going to
be a huge problem that affects and
likely shortens the lives of many many
millions of people so I think part of
what we're doing when we imagine these
kind of apocalyptic scenarios associated
with climate change is almost like
trying to use human psychology to
understand the scope of what we're
talking about because it's really really
hard to understand the scope of what
we're talking about like it's it's
really hard to understand how small
changes over long
of time will have profound effects on
many people but it's really easy to
imagine like smallpox running rampant
through a population so I think it's
almost a way of trying to like uh-huh
trying to like give it a form that makes
sense to us and like makes us feel
adequately like oh we have to deal with
this yeah maybe yeah like say but but I
don't really like that strategy I would
prefer to say like here's our graduation
I also haven't heard scientists being
like the biggest problem we're gonna
face is smallpox from global warming I
haven't really heard that one no I just
think like on them but on the margins
not not not within scientific
communities but on the margins of people
like trying to understand it I agree
it's not a good strategy I just think
like maybe that's part of what's going
on all right John this question comes
from Emily who asks dear Hank and John I
have naturally curly hair occasionally I
straighten my hair if on the day that I
die my hair is straight
will I be buried with my hair straight
or will it be washed and styled in my
usual curly way Thank You Emily well I
really appreciate you coming to us and
yeah with your question that's for for
mortuary scientists because I don't know
if you know this but Hank just as I was
briefly in Divinity School before
dropping out and deciding I didn't want
to be a minister Hank was briefly in
mortuary school before dropping out and
deciding that he didn't want to run a
funeral home so I won - Hank well yeah I
think like whatever you want like write
it down first and everybody will do what
you want to do but I think yeah that's
how it works right
well by assume most people don't most
people aren't like put me in this suit
and like do my hair this way and I want
to be wearing this watch yeah what is
your will say oh god not none of that
yeah definitely not my will is just like
I believe it says something like just
make sure that Hank gets nothing
Hank will inherit my stereo boombox and
nothing else there's a little note
inside my will that says Hank if you had
not stolen and sold my
baseball cards on eBay when we were
children you would be a wealthy man
right now but instead here's my stereo
boombox I remember that I remember
specifically like think when I was young
thinking about like like when I was like
eight or nine thinking about like if I
died who would get my boombox because it
was like my favorite thing in the world
I had like two tape decks and it was you
know had big speakers and you could fill
it with like 8000 D batteries and you
could take it portable and I remember
being like man now I gotta make sure I
know who's gonna get this if I go yeah
and like one like and like like I I
don't know if I don't know if you were
on the shortlist John
oh I don't take it personally you
shouldn't bother me I all right I want I
want you to be happy and if that means
not leaving me your boombox I'm okay
with it although I guess you won't be
happy almost by definition I wonder what
that stereo boombox is doing now I I
have a pretty good guess oh I have a
pretty good guess that it turned out to
die before you turned out I guess that's
alright ah it is somewhere in a landfill
gathering dust oh no I can't imagine
it's gathering dust it's probably sealed
to the outside it probably hasn't been
touched by air and it'll be discovered
in like 2000 years as people are digging
through our remains looking for a cure
to smallpox yeah don't dig for a cure of
the smallpox it'll just I'm just kidding
smallpox is not coming back it is the
sink I would argue the single greatest
achievement in the history of the human
species is the eradication of smallpox
and I'm very proud of it and it's not
coming back we did it that's right let's
let's take take credit where credit is
due humans you got it you did that thing
and that was a good thing god we do so
many things poorly but we did eliminate
smallpox and we're close to eliminating
polio and it makes me thin and one day
we will eliminate malaria and I all of
my hope is in our ability to kill things
yeah good it's what humans are best at
extinction are usually usually bad but
but sometimes we do extinction in the
right way John that's right
we do extinction every way
poorly well in the middle we've got it
covered if you need to go extinct you've
found this species for you oh man I've
loved alright if that were only the case
there are quite a number of species that
I would totally eradicate absolutely
true it's true
yeah people are always like what like
you like all species serve a purpose
like what why like what purpose to tick
serve and I'm like well I my problem is
with your first premise not real they're
like like sure yes they have they have a
niche in the ecosystem but like a tick
like if every tick died everything would
be fine everything would be better for
everyone if every tick died they agree
they exist for their own benefit and no
one else's you know Hank we need to
start a an organization an anti an anti
tick organization that just says no more
ticks just humans you have killed
thousands and thousands of species focus
healing energies on ticks let's find a
way to make them into burgers then we'll
kill them in five minutes are we still
talking about birds and airports no I
think we're talking about people's dead
hairs what today's podcast is brought to
you by ticks ticks on their way out if
Hank has anything to say about it except
for this podcast also additionally being
brought to you by Amazon comms new
series the tick based on Ben edlund's
comic book series it's very good and
should not be eradicate you know what I
just to briefly pause the sponsorship
saying I thought for a second there you
were going to do our first actual
sponsorship by the way we're gonna have
actual sponsors on the podcast we don't
know how we're going to integrate it yet
but we finally had some actual sponsors
reach out to us and we were like they
were like we know that you're not to
commercial than we were like we'd like
to be so I hope I hope you won't mind us
selling you mad
Tricia's slash websites slash Amazon's
new series to tick but we will make it
clear when we're being paid to say
something because you know we'll read
the copy in a way that makes us sound
like we don't mean it no I'm just
kidding I'm will
we'll make it clear so back to the point
though today's podcast is also brought
to you by the Portland Timbers the
Portland Timbers America's number one
Oregon men's soccer team since way back
in 2009 and finally this podcast is
brought to you by fake sponsors fake
sponsors not going anywhere even if we
have some real sponsors yeah but we are
not we are we are gonna say yes to some
real sponsors because yeah but we're
gonna keep doing the fake ones that's
what I said on Twitter like we're
thinking about it people were like as
long as you don't get rid of the fake
ones cuz I like that part no I'm glad
people like that that's a good that's
that's positive okay Hank do you have
another question for me I do this one is
from Meredith who asks dear Hank and
John I just recently got into a
relationship with a lovely boy and it's
going very well so far the only problem
I have is there's somewhat of an
intellectual disparity between us he's
an English major attending your alma
mater John who absolutely adores reading
and has read more books than I can
fathom I however having dyslexia and
ADHD don't tend to enjoy reading as a
pastime because it quite literally hurts
my brain I think I've so far been able
to maintain the illusion that I'm
decently well-read but I'm afraid he
will soon find out that I'm not and be
very disappointed he frequently makes
references to classic literature that I
know nothing about and I sorted a smile
and pretend like I know what's going on
I know that I'm smart in lots of other
ways and that's valuable but this is
something that's really important to him
and I want to be able to talk with him
about it please provide me with advice
and/or summaries of important books that
I should know about which I had a better
sign off Meredith alright John The Great
Gatsby what's that one uh Gatsby turned
out alright in the end it was what
preyed on Gatsby what foul dust railed
in the wake of his dreams that temper
rarely hold on let me Google the rest of
the quote basically that's all you have
to say though if you're talking about
Gatsby you just have to say you just
have to you just have to quote that that
line what foul dust
that floated in the wake of his dreams I
didn't even get that part right but that
temporary closed out my interest in the
aboard of sorrows and short-winded
elations of men who among us does not
know that feeling of temporarily the
temporary closing out of one's interest
in the abortive sorrows and short-winded
ovations of men that's actually one of
the feelings that I know the best that I
have I have seen rendered on the page
the least but yeah that's that's all you
need to know about Gatsby gasps we
turned out alright in the end it was
what what preyed on Gatsby it was that
foul dust trailing in the wake of his
dreams do you need any others
what about Old Man and the sea Oh a man
goes out to sea spoiler alert
catches a fish but then the catching of
the fish almost destroys him it's man
versus nature at a time when Hemingway
believed that somehow so it's to me
Hemingway and especially old man in the
sea is extremely like it like constantly
contradicts itself like it has a
constantly shifting opinion on the
relationship between man and nature that
I find annoying but lots of people find
brilliant
what about like Terry Pratchett's
monstrous regiment okay I've only read
one terry pratchet book so on a world
that is flat and and disk-like yeah okay
that's all I've got nothing about just
wizards or Wars or standoff wizards and
other things as well other things as
well so one of those like I so I would
say actually one of the secrets to this
whole thing this question is that
everybody in in my experience everybody
I've ever talked to seems smarter than
me because I have a different set of
like illusions and a different set of
understandings than they do and whenever
they say something that I haven't read
or seen
or looked at or whatever I feel like an
idiot but of course like I don't have
access to their entire encyclopedia of
references Meredith I think that like
whether or not you have read old man in
the sea has very little to do with
either how smart you are or or how
effectively you can contextualize
yourself in in the universe I just don't
think it's that I say this as a writer
like I don't think reading any
individual book is that important yes I
just don't like and I think I think
there are lots of ways to engage
intellectually with the world and I bet
your boyfriend understands that or else
he shoes yeah I mean there's something
to be said for having shared cultural
experiences and that can be any kind of
media but it's him certainly be books
yeah but yeah also lots of people have
really great relationships that like
were raised in different countries and
and never watched any of the same TV
shows that read the same books because
they were reading in different languages
like it's it's totally possible to have
a relationship without like a hundred
percent of your interests being shared
and and but but I do think that it's
good to be honest about that sooner yeah
yeah the thing I would just suggest is
to find places where you can connect to
each other you know cultural stuff that
you can connect whether it's art or TV
shows or whatever and connect and also
like yeah don't let it get you to down
if it's like like there's like Katherine
it was a big fan and it is still a big
fan of musicals and and and also like
some old movies and we'll also always
like sort of look at me ask ants when
I'm like I do not know that thing you
are referring to and she will like be a
little bit of like a little bit prat
like like looking a little bit down on
me but like it's all in good fun
and does not mean that like she thinks
that I'm a bad person or that and and
yeah so if it just because like you
don't have that thing in common and just
because like there may be some polite
joshing around it does not mean that
like oh you're so like uneducated or
whatever too like and if it's the kind
of thing that's that that
is gonna mess a little bit with your
confidence I think also be honest about
that with I agree Hank we need to get to
an important issue that many people
brought up after a recent episode of the
podcast it's obviously a contentious
topic and one that I think I I actually
wasn't in on this episode and if I had
been I think we would have handled it a
little differently and maybe a little
less dismissively but I just want to be
honest about it and I acknowledge the
feedback that we got which was
overwhelmingly negative about the biting
of popsicles
Connie writes dear Hank John and Travis
once again Connie I was not in on this
conversation so you can just say dear
Hank and Travis because I was not
involved I'd like to point out that
biting popsicles is a better way to use
popsicles if your goal is to cool down
if you wait until a bit of the popsicle
melts before licking it off you are
allowing the popsicle to absorb heat
from the Sun this means that less of
your body heat will be absorbed over the
entire eating of the popsicle pushing
the problem even further consuming sugar
kicks up your metabolism and makes you
warmer anyways popsicles are instant
gratification for little overall gain it
seems like you should be drinking water
and consuming hot things instead to make
you start sweating evaporation is a
cooling process please check out the
links below and then there are a lot of
sources so there you go indeed Wow
oh yeah coldest whoo mmm yes there are a
lot of a lot of things I'll say fine
then just swallow bunch of Ice Cube's if
that's what yeah well okay I don't want
to raise more hackles though on the
fighting composition so I will just say
that I have no opinion on this matter
and I think that people should use their
popsicles in whichever way they want
yeah I apologize for everybody who felt
who felt that my treatment of popsicle
biters was and I think that that was in
the that was in the oh no oh yeah yeah
yeah that was okay I remember now I
thought that that was like a patron
exclusive or something it wasn't
everybody got that one
yeah that was our pod calm promotion
episode but yeah use popsicles however
you want this this question comes from
Sarah who might be my wife and writes
Dear John and Hank I'm in need of some
dubious advice my husband wants to shave
his head for the past year now he's been
telling me again and again that he just
wants to know what his head looks like
but I just want to know what my head
looks like but what if it grows back
different what if it decides not to grow
back at all what if it looks weird
also if you want a reference point he
looks like Hank
but with dark brown hair I mean it's
very well good be my wife
I mean that's yeah that sounds like that
sounds a little like you PS I haven't
seen any tweets from lien MAHS lately
has he lost his passion for his mission
I wouldn't say that he's lost his
passion for his mission because Hank
made a big to-do about how I would
eventually lose interest in Leon Maas
and I'm not willing to give him the
satisfaction that's all I'm saying on
that topic Hank what do you do when your
spouse wants to shave their head so that
they know what their head looks like but
you are worried that it will grow back
different or not grow back at all um I
think that you should be worried about
what he will look like when his head is
shaved and also maybe that he will like
it so much that he will keep doing it
and you won't like it because maybe it's
a real good maybe it's a good maybe it's
a good feeling for on that just having
an heir on it I don't know maybe it
would be and and maybe he just would
like to not have to handle deal with all
of the the hair coming out of his is
noggin but but it's got it's not gonna
come back weird it's gonna come back
normal and that's there's pretty pretty
broad spike a set of data supporting
that including every person who's ever
shaved their head so that's that you
shouldn't be too concerned about that
but but you but I would do you know make
sure that it's like okay if this is
about you just learning what your head
looks like let's together we will make
this sacrifice and we will learn what
your head looks like because that's
apparently something I mean it's kind of
a weird thing to not know now that
you've said it now that now that you
have made this argument to me I'm like
okay I don't know what my head looks
like I have had this head my whole life
and it has always been covered in hair I
don't know what's under there there
could be like a weird like pattern of
moles that like
in the perfect shape of a turtle and I
would never know and so I'd like
absolutely maybe this is something that
he just needs to know about himself and
he's tired of not knowing it but Hank
I'd like to point out one thing that's
very that's that's a real consideration
here that nobody's mentioned yet which
is that if you shave your head it will
definitely contribute to hair loss you
will lose all of those hairs oh yes yes
the hairs will be lost
but it should not inactivate any of the
current follicles I don't know I don't
know what those words mean I was just
trying to make a joke I also I also just
want to say that if you do find that you
shave your head and you have moles in
the exact shape of a turtle that maybe
we could use that for the cover of my
new book Turtles all the way down yeah
well maybe that I mean I could Photoshop
that for you if you want no no no no no
God why did you create now it is an
inevitability that someone will make
that and it's terrible terrible news for
me this is one of the worst things that
came from this week's podcast yeah but
but I would I would if I were you person
who asked the question I don't have it
in front of me just make sure that you
like agree that there's a time limit on
the head shaving if you really don't
like it like don't like the idea then
you know his his hair is in some in some
respects your hair hmm I don't know that
I agree with that Beck I don't know that
no marriage is a fusing of the hair as
well as a fusing of the soil I don't
even really think marriage is a fusing
of the soul for the record I just want
to go out go out and say that I'm not
totally convinced on Hanks position in
response okay that works it's out where
you get you got to get the joint big
knockout and then everybody is in charge
of everybody else's hair yep nope nope
nope I know lots of happily married
people who actually don't have shared
finances even it's it's a subject of
great interest to me because Sarah and I
have had
finances since like three weeks into our
relationship yeah Catherine and I used
to have a whiteboard where we would keep
track of who owed who what and then at
the end of the month we'd sort of
balance it out and be like ten bucks
right no that's a lot extra yeah at the
moment we moved in together we were like
uh let's just go ahead and mix all the
books together and also just get the one
bank account and in some ways marriage
was the smaller step once you've mixed
your library with someone else's library
it's very very difficult to break up
alright John I take back my comment
about help spouse ODEs their spouses
hair yeah great good really good
retraction Hank it's time to get to the
news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon what is
the news from Mars this week John if you
go on to if you go on to YouTube you
know about YouTube yeah oh yeah and
there is a new video that it's it's
basically fan art as far as I can tell
this was not produced by NASA there's
this video called vivid Mars and it is
it is footage of both the launch of the
Mars Reconnaissance Orbiter and also
some of the amazing pictures it has
taken on the red or of the red planet
because it's orbiting the planet the
hi-rise camera is one of the heaviest
biggest cameras we've ever sent it to a
planetary mission and this video cuts
together these amazing beautiful images
with some really great music and and and
some good stuff
footage of MRO heading heading to the
Red Planet and man if you just it's
really super HD you gotta like open it
up on the full screen monitor or on your
TV or something and just spend these
three minutes watching this video
because it it makes me feel very good
feelings about us as a species
and about and about that beautiful
University we live in
it's called vivid Mars it's on a YouTube
channel called ka mi kami and it's it's
just frickin gorgeous it's like wow they
did an amazing amazing job of putting
this together I will do that right after
we get off this podcast because that
sounds lovely I also have news from AFC
Wimbledon in fact for considering that
it is still the off season I have an
astonishing amount of news from AFC well
first off AFC Wimbledon have a new kit
manufacturer Hank as you know all the
big clubs sign kit deals with like Nike
or Puma or Under Armour or whomever and
AFC Wimbledon's new kit deal is with
Puma Puma the maker of those shoes that
Hank wears every time he's doing a
concert yeah I have to wear I mean I
don't I usually wear my my boring shoes
but when I need to look good I put on my
Pumas it's true that's right
it's true that's right Puma by the way
is welcome to sponsor this podcast as
well as AFC Wimbledon but we're very
glad to have them joining the AFC
Wimbledon sponsorship family alongside
the video game football manager your
golf travel comm and of course me also
in news from AFC Wimbledon Dom Polian
has left the club for Bradford City
another striker
leaves the team Tom Elliot left earlier
this season
now Poe Leon's left it's at but you
could put up a show but Neal hardly did
say we feel that we are strong enough in
that department to let him leave but I
who exactly is making us strong in that
department we still have the Montserrat
II and Messi Lyle Taylor but can he
score goals alone can he score the 30 or
40 goals we would need from him I don't
know I'm a little nervous it's nervous
times there's been a lot of selling and
not a lot of buying yet for for AFC
Wimbledon and lastly probably the most
important news hank you may remember
that there was a petition by certain
people to have the the
Elden greyhound stadium where they do
the greyhound races listed as an
architectural masterpiece so that it
could never be taken down and turned
into a of Saladin's new stadium yeah and
then because of the English election
there there's a rule in England where
they you know they only have six week
election periods as opposed to America
where our elections never end and then
when they do and the results are in
dispute for the rest of all time yeah in
England they only have like a six week
election cycle so you cannot make any
kind of big decision within six weeks or
an election so that you're not seen to
be yeah so that you're not seen to be
like trying to influence thing or
strings or whatever so the the decision
was delayed and delayed and delayed
because this election business that's
been going on in the United Kingdom but
finally it came out that the greyhound
stadium is not going to be listed that
should be the last major hurdle between
AFC wimbledon and final real let's get
some boots on the ground and cut some
ribbons and start to dig permission to
to for AFC wimbledon to build a new
stadium in their historic homeland so
that's very very exciting that is i do
it man so you so so what's the thing
that they sing they sing show me the way
to plan lane yeah so they've they've
gone now
25 years without without a home in their
home you know they used to have the
stadium for many years called plow lane
and it was taken away from them and and
then they had to ground share with
Crystal Palace and then the club of
course was taken away and moved to
Milton Keynes and it's so they sing this
song show me the way to plough Lane I'm
tired and I want to go home I had a
football ground 20 years ago and I want
one of my own and I think the most
unexpected result possible from that
song would be that they are actually
going home to plough Lane but that seems
like what it what is going to happen
they they've truly shown the world the
way to plough Lane
and uh hopefully for that 2019 2020
season hanky you and I and all of
nerdfighteria will be in that Stadium to
celebrate their first game everybody
everyone everybody's every everyone from
the whole world I will charter all of
the planes no one can go anywhere on
that day all the planes go to London you
look at you go to the airport and the
birds and the humans are all all only
going to London and all the birds will
be stuck in the airport completely
unable to go to their destination
wherever that was
alright Hank what did we learn today
John we learned that a nice cool earth
is keeping some infectious diseases
locked away so that people can't get
them but in that I think thank you cool
earth you're the best you're so cool
thanks cooler we learned that driving is
dangerous and scary but is still
currently a necessity for a lot of
people we learned that John was never
ever going to inherit my stereo boombox
which now is locked deep silently
and darkly somewhere underground and
speaking of that we learned that Hank
was briefly a student of the mortuary
sciences don't start rumors John no
sorry we learned that I may or may not
have a bunch of turtle moles on my head
Oh God
thanks for listening to this podcast you
can email us at Hank and John at
gmail.com send us your questions we
always appreciate it yeah I think Hank
does the credits not me so I don't know
yeah this podcast is is produced by
Sheridan Gibson and rosianna halse rojas
our social media person is Victoria bon
giorno Nick Nick Jenkins is our editor
who makes all of a sound wave better and
funnier than we actually are
we have a patreon at patreon.com slash
dear Hank and John where you can support
this podcast by which we mean we use
that money to pay for things that our
company where we make scishow crash
course and stuff because they take that
much to run this thing
and I knew all can also you can also get
our weekly our weekly patreon only
podcast this week in Ryan's there and if
you are wanting to ask more questions
John already told you about our email
address but we are also on Twitter at
Hank green and at John Green can use the
hashtag dear Hank and John we I don't
want to end the podcast under this when
I keep talking you're my bud and I write
but I guess we have to end it not only
do we have to we have to end it but only
so that we can go make a different
podcast help this weekend Ryan well yeah
okay so it's not over yet well thanks
for potting with me Jonna thanks
everybody for listening and as they say
in our hometown don't forget to be
awesome
[Music]